Fox News visibly and brazenly continues
to lie about the Twitter bombshell
Twitter files which flopped softer than
a wet noodle
um this one is going to be I I know that
this isn't going to work as well for
people just listening today because
there's a visual component here play
along for a moment and then I'll explain
it all to you I'm gonna play a clip for
you of Ted Cruz Cancun Cruise senator
from Texas appearing on Fox News this
was uh yesterday
to talk about the Twitter files and if
you're watching keep an eye on the
screen
and see if you can identify something
weird on the screen
let's listen and then we are going to
discuss
look Jesse what what Elon Musk has
released is evidence of corruption that
goes to the highest level of government
it goes to the highest level of the FBI
and it goes to the highest level of big
Tech we've known for a long time that
big Tech is censoring conservatives but
what Elon did here is he just laid naked
all of the lies that the corporate media
has told because it's clear during the
2020 election over and over and over
again the Biden the Biden campaign and
the DNC would reach out to their buddies
at Twitter and say hey we don't like
this and their response is handled and
they take it down over and over and over
again and in particular all of the
exchange back and forth when the hunter
Biden laptop story broke it was evidence
that the leadership at Twitter knew
within hours that that their ridiculous
fake excuse that it was hacked was a
ridiculous fake excuse to eat wow I mean
it's I don't know that there's anything
true in what Ted Cruz is saying but let
me call your attention to a couple of
different things at the start of the
segment the title at the bottom of the
screen that fox puts up says Biden White
House
had Direct Line
to Twitter sensors okay what Biden White
House what Biden White House this all
took place in 2020 when Joe Biden was
not the president of the United States
there was no Biden White House now you
want to write this off as some kind of
technicality because it's really not
there is no such entity as the Biden
White House unless you believe in some
kind of strange time travel that
Democrats had access to in 2020.
also direct line
they had an email address
they had an email address and as I've
said before
if you want to make the case that a
political campaign not an Administration
that a political campaign the Biden
campaign
should have had to use the same system I
have to use right like you know on
Twitter we're on Twitter right now if I
don't like a tweet I have to click the
little thing and then report tweet right
and I gotta fill out a form and do a
whole different thing if you want to
make the case that they should have had
to do that rather than emailing someone
at Twitter when revenge porn of Hunter
Biden was posted I'm glad to have that
conversation with you maybe that's true
maybe they should have to do the same
thing I have to do rather than email
someone but that's not really a
bombshell that's a little issue around
the edges the main story here
is not really a story this was about
content nude images of Hunter Biden that
he didn't release
that violates Twitter's guidelines about
revenge porn it's content that was
illegal in just about every state in the
United States and I believe against
federal law as well although I'd have to
refresh my memory on that back from the
start of the hunter Biden story
um and and the entire story Biden White
House didn't exist direct line it was an
email address this exposes corruption at
the highest levels
not really maybe they should have had to
use the report tweet function rather
than an email
it flopped and again I don't know if Ted
Cruz knows it flopped but is lying or
doesn't realize that it flopped Ted Cruz
is smart enough
to probably realize that so I would lean
on he's being dishonest rather than
ignorant but with Ted Cruz you never
really know